She arrived like a monster.
Sweeping away Puerto Rico entirely.
Hurricane Maria would become
the second deadliest hurricane
in US history.
FEMA came to my house.
Two months later,
they told me, "No, you can't live here."
One day I will go back to my island.
Transitional Shelter Assistance
provides hotel rooms
for displaced Puerto Ricans to live in.
Six months, here at the hotel.
Give me a kiss!
I met her here at the hotel.
They are like family to me.
Move.
How do we get out of this city,
which is very difficult to live in?
FEMA is ending assistance
for Puerto Ricans
as many still struggle.
Everybody's watching. They don't have
the guts to tell, "That's what happened."
Now, where? That's what we don't know.
I don't know if we will have
that help at hand.
If they will help us get a place,
or if we're going to be in the streets.